sou professor na faculdade de ciências e
tecnologia da universidade nova de
lisboa e nos 18 anos de trabalho nesta
instituição já leccionei quase todo tipo
de chip nas de matemática são em geral
disciplinas com um grande número de uns
gente 300 e alguns por exemplo neste
momento surgem de uma disciplina com 323
alunos é quase metade destes auditório
por mais que eu queira eu nunca vou
conseguir conhecer estes jovens ea minha
relação com o els vai ser sempre muito
técnica
possivelmente fria os ruins aos
conteúdos da disciplina
há dois anos atrás após uma mudança de
visão e também estratégia que aconteceu
na minha instituição vive uma nova
experiência de ensino e é essa que eu
vos vai encontar aceitar e fazer parte
de um grupo de 40 professores de todos
os tratamentos da faculade para
implementarmos selecionarmos uma
disciplina diferente é uma disciplina
diferente no ponto de vista dos
objetivos na forma de nos relacionarmos
com o suns e também no período do ano em
que acontece sem alterarmos o programa
das disciplinas técnicas conseguir
libertar no calendário escolar dos
nossos jovens cinco semanas entre o
primeiro eo segundo semestre para que
nessas semanas não tenham a oportunidade
de praticar e de desenvolver aquelas
competências que em geral não são
fornecidas pelas disciplinas técnicas
mas cujo mercado de trabalho tanto
procura news
este é o período das competências
complementares
todos os anos nestas cinco semanas dos
nossos alunos encontram disciplinas
obrigatórias e avaliar nas relacionadas
diretamente com o mercado de trabalho no
primeiro ano encontram a disciplina de
competências transversais para ciências
e tecnologia é a disciplina que eu ia
que o grupo de 40 professores fazemos
para esta disciplina tem como objetivo
motivar os alunos numa perspectiva do
mercado de trabalho o que é que o tanque
fazer hoje
em paralelo o meu curso para melhorar o
meu currículo e aumentar a
empregabilidade no futuro uma palavrinha
as faltas dos professores ctt
nós somos um grupo de professores 40
professores muito acostumados a lecionar
a disciplina somos especialistas aceitar
o acionar uma disciplina como esta foi
um desafio foi um vestido a camisola
foi também um atrevimento desde o que
tivemos de encontrar tempo para inúmeras
formações relacionadas com o tema nós
não conhecíamos um mercado de trabalho
depois tivemos de encontrar tempo
disponibilidade física eu diria que
também mental para durante cinco semanas
todos os dias acompanharam um grupo de
cerca 30 alunos que nos foi entregue
passámos de um extremo ao outro de uma
situação não conhecemos os nossos jovens
para outra onde o chão nosso
estivemos com e aos 12 horas por semana
num total de 60 horas como calculam em
uma disciplina destas para temos muito
mais do que o programa da disciplina
convivemos com eles e elas partilham
preocupações e nós crianças
deixamos de ser aqui os professores à
distância e passamos a ser os
professores deus dispensaram de banho
estes jovens universitários não tem um
professor deus talvez desde a primária
eu queria chamar agora que própria mim a
minha primeira turma de 60 e 70
estes alunos marcaram e eu acho que os
mercados também e para vos contar o
funcionamento da disciplina
não vou usar algumas situações que vivi
com meus vou começar pelo primeiro dia
são dez da manhã a uma segunda feira
janeiro de 2003
temos os 1.200 alunos da fct
distribuídos pelos professores etc e
1.200 alunos do 1º ano teve o grupo em
sua sala mas todos ao mesmo tempo
este é o meu grupo de alunos
a primeira novidade é quando estes
alguns chegaram a ser de 70 anos não se
conheciam
foram distribuídos ao vitória -
importante chegam com ar preocupado com
sair a primeira aula com uma história
particular a qual eu nunca tinha dado
importância mas que agora fazia sentido
é a história da minha única entrevista
de emprego que o partido também convosco
este sou eu a 18 anos atrás eu fui muito
estudioso muito estudioso mesmo daqueles
que passam as férias de verão fechado
num quarto a melhorar 1 17
é claro que eu melhorava neste ano
recebeu o prêmio de melhor aluno da
faculdade e comecei a trabalhar no mundo
acadêmico mas caía realizar uma
entrevista de emprego em uma companhia
de seguros precisava de um matemático eu
enviei o currículo e fui a entrevista
em entrevista não correu nada bem
literalmente o que se passou foi espanha
nesta figura
eu era matemático e pronto ninguém
estava mais interessado nisso
queriam saber das minhas atividades de
férias dos meus amigos e até das minhas
namoradas e na estranha e quando dias
mais tarde e por carta
a resposta a esta entrevista de emprego
dizia qualquer coisa assim apesar do
percurso académico brilhante as
características do cláudio não se
adequam às dos restantes elementos da
equipa e para mim era como se eu fosse
um carro com um motor muito potente mas
não estavam interessados nas minhas
rodas
será que este tipo tem rodas para andar
com especial é que é o cloud um para
além das suas notas
como é que eu cômica como é que eu já
era o seu tempo será que alguma vez
conseguirá liderar uma equipa o que é
que um time vá tem espírito de
iniciativa é controlado
tudo isto são competências que o mercado
de trabalho procurando os nossos jovens
a anj e isto não se adquire se nos
ficharam joão quarto a melhorar 17 ct
porque o motor de um carro é importante
as rodas também no final do primeiro dia
os nossos alunos tenham compreendido a
importância desta disciplina e
naturalmente nos dias que eu chegarão
motivados criam trabalhar estas
competências o que fizemos então eu e os
outros colegas e os 40 colegas foi
desenvolver com ele uma série de
atividades que tenhamos construído ao
longo da nossa formação mais tentative
da diz muito variadas atividades que vão
da carreira que os levam para fora da
sala de aulas que obrigam a dar a sua
opinião a confrontarem-se são casos
as ações da johnson de soluções
problemas demonstrações em os nações
é com este tipo de actividade onde
fazemos para aprender ganhar confiança e
também nos conhecermos que desenvolvem
estas competências acaba de nos indicar
duas razões para o sucesso desta
disciplina os alunos compreendem bem a
sua importância para o futuro e
atividades escolhidas
vou indicar outras uma delas foi o
trabalho em equipa
os nossos alunos trabalharam sempre em
grupos 4 nem mais nem menos
todos sabemos a importância do trabalho
em grupo
a nossa particularidade é que os grupos
mudavam todas as semanas
isto motiva os alunos obrigados a
conquistar em constante - e no final das
cinco semanas todos tenham confrontado
com um outro aspecto importante nesta
disciplina foi a avaliação ao contrário
do que seria de esperar os nossos alunos
foram fortemente avaliados e esse é o
meu cheiro excel com os mais de 80
variações que eu produzi para cada um
deus para ter emprego chegarem à nota
final
todos os dias e os furtos foram
avaliados a tudo é tudo trabalho
individual de trabalho em equipa
no final da semana recebem em suas notas
e na semana a seguir podem melhorar um
outro aspecto em algumas semanas fizemos
lhes uma pequena maldade não sabíamos
que era uma maldade no início eu
estiveram a trabalhar em grupos de
quatro
jogamos num saco como estes com 39
feijões queda feijão representou um
ponto
colocamos em cima da mesa e dizemos
agora avaliem se retirem os feijões que
merecem pelo vosso trabalho em grupo
não imaginam como reagem mal esta
atividade eles não conseguem dizer cara
a cara os colegas
eu trabalhei mais no futuro e portanto
merece mais regiões como não conseguem
fazer isso
viram-se contra nós efe lam existem
querem que terminemos com esta avaliação
porque os que estavam mesmo é que o saco
tivesse 40 feições porque sentem o
problema resolvido
deviam 10 por cada um mas não são 40 são
39 vem práticas quatro razões para o
sucesso desta disciplina
eu podia indicar muitas mais
mas eu deixei para o fim àquela pra mim
foi mais surpreendente é o mais
brasileiro foi a possibilidade de
conviver com estes jovens de partilhar
com eles
experiências muitas histórias eu contei
aos meus alunos sobre situações que
passaram comigo e situações onde nem
sempre eu fui um herói por exemplo para
eles falar da importância de ir à
justiça e só aí dá histórias que eu
passei na cidade do méxico
eu fui fazer mestrado a cidade do méxico
meu deus eu sei
diretamente do meu quarto pra uma cidade
com 25 milhões de habitantes
para mim todos os dias vêm viver nesta
cidade ainda hoje eu sonho com ela
valeu tanto a pena para lhes falar de
gestão do tempo mostrar às amigas que
restarem
eu sou muito organizado ou fora da
procura de uma folha na minha secretária
também têm dificuldade em dizer não e
quem tem dificuldade em dizer não anda
sem muita tarefa é importante sabermos
dizer não na altura certa para
cumprirmos os nossos objetivos
um dia estávamos a falar de inteligência
emocional e o conta a história da minha
bola de sabão é o último que o desconto
ainda ter o ct
todos nós vivemos dentro de uma bola de
sabão que nos protege do mundo
protege-nos mas também nos torna egoísta
há dias em que esta bola está muito
negra e num desses dias eu resolvi ir à
natação
já agora eu passei a fazer desporto
depois da minha entrevista de emprego
entrei no balneário recusar a ver quem
estava em volta em aparelhos como sem
respiro do pentáurea me toca
bom dia eu também vim treinar
era como se eu tivesse acordado olha aí
e era um minuto hindu que tinha no
máximo oito anos tinha tido a ousadia de
reinventar a minha bola de sabão para
deixar o dia mais feliz
vocês podem fazer isto todos os dias eu
não sei como é que conta esta história
mas lembro que sala 3 mil por instantes
eles ficaram imóveis
mas como são jovens e os jovens não são
muito dados a 6 x 1 deus levantou o
braço ele é professor nunca mais deixou
de dizer bom dia no balneário é verdade
eu digo bom dia até os armários foram
cinco semanas incríveis daquelas onde
somos muito fluido importante ainda mais
pelo tempo passar
no último dia de aulas
lembro que um tipo de deus mais ou menos
assim
meus escritos aprendemos tanta coisa
juntos
ainda bem que estamos a terminar porque
já não têm histórias para contar o que
eu queria mesmo era que cada um de vocês
por gás nesta instrumentos que plantamos
em ctct e que se fossem empregados no
final das vossas licenciaturas todos
serão árvores grandes robustas muito
melhor do que o que eu fui na vossa
idade eu acredito tanto em vocês
eu vou ficar na facul lado enquanto não
deixarem se calhar durante este período
que estiver a act não fiz dois artigos
da chave ficou com 32 novas histórias
para contar aos novos colegas porque o
conheço tão bem
esta era a altura em que os viam abrir a
porta da sala e sair porque o mundo
estava à espera de deus mas não
levantaram os todos ao mesmo tempo
alguns com lágrimas nos olhos
aproximaram-se odiaram abraçaram deram
um beijo lugar a minha mão e ficarmos
dentro da sala de aulas mais três cortes
dora simplesmente repetir as histórias
que tenhamos contar uns aos outros
o professor contornos tantas histórias
a certa altura um deus desse algo que eu
nunca mais vou esquecer
professor não sabe quantos mudou
eu sou matemático e até há quem diga que
a matemática é fria e que não tem
sentimentos
eu continuo a manter contacto com estes
jovens em dois anos pra cá sempre porque
nos encontramos na faculdade é uma festa
beijinhos abraços sempre que alguma
coisa acontece do boa em c&t trocamos um
em maio este é um dos muitos e mails que
eu passei a receber na minha caixa de
correio de há dois anos para cá
o fábio foi meu aluno já este ano e
antes de ir de férias de verão
despediu-se que nem assim o fábio está
aqui conosco esta tarde de tudo aquilo
que este maio tem de bom para o futuro
do fábio e do trono lento
eu queria destacar o facto de não falar
bem do professor cláudio eu falo dos
grandes professores que o fábio tem da
nossa st
aquela nossa outra família meus caros
esta é uma realidade que temos
implementado na faculdade já há dois
anos estamos a preparar o terceiro ano
este período das cinco semanas
é muito mais do que o período das
competências complementares
é um período da faculdade é nossa amiga
onde estabelecem laços até entre
professores e alunos
imaginem se isto é inovador no panorama
do ensino superior português
tenho certeza que sim mas quando
ocupamos na história
este é o espírito da universidade na
idade média
um lugar onde mestres e discípulos para
que a vão muito mais do conhecimento
científico conviviam estavam juntos por
gosto
obrigado
o povo